well good afternoon everybody Welcome to
our Wednesday weekly
webinar um after today's uh speakers are
going to be Dr David
Sakowski and Shandra Zan
balinsky and we'll uh give you a little
more information about them here in a
second but uh first off what a little
reminder we have one more webinar after
today uh Dr Clifford Hall and the person
who's gone today Dr Julie Gard Robinson
will be presenting uh the final
one uh don't forget these are also being
recorded and they'll uh then uploaded to
YouTube and those will be posted on the
field of fork website if you ever want
to go back and listen to them or you
know of somebody else who missed it who
want to want to watch and also don't
forget for questions just type them down
in the lefthand corner there number five
here on this screen and uh the speakers
will be able to watch them down the chat
area and answer those questions
a little later one more thing to go over
before we get started is the shirt
survey that Julie always wants to remind
you about you should be getting that
sent you in an email but it's pretty
important to fill those out because this
is a grant project and um those
responses are very important um to kind
of finish up the information you know to
for research uh for the grant and she's
also going to be picking people at
random to win prizes for those that
actually have completed the survey so
another B us to do that so today's topic
is food safety inspections and audit
requirements and as I mentioned our
speakers today are going to be David
Sakowski and Shandra Zan balinsky uh
David Sakowski is an associate professor
in the department of Agra business and
applied economics his teaching
responsibilities include courses in
agricultural law farm and Agri business
management and food law Shan Rima
balinsky serves Burley County as the
family and consumer Sciences agent with
indu extension service after graduating
from the University of Minnesota and the
Twin Cities she became a food science
technician with the research and
development team at General Mills
developing new and Innovative frozen
food products shra chose to return to
North Dakota to be near her family upon
redeploying from Iraq in
2009 she furthered her food science and
food safety background with Cloverdale
Foods company where she transitioned
into the director of Technical Services
position leading the food safety and
quality control effort there she was the
technical team lead during audits from
FDA USDA sqf local food audits in
according to the food code and several
other informal
inspections and now I'll pass it along
to today's two speakers go ahead guys
all right well I'll take it from here
thank you Scott nice
introduction and I just really
appreciate all that he did to get us up
here technologically um I as he
mentioned we'll be co-presenting with
David and we're happy to bring you
today's topic which is is being ready
for food safety inspections and
Audits and we are going to elaborate
today on really two different categories
of these types of inspections and audits
the government does have their say in
how we produce food as we would provide
it for others not necessarily in your
own kitchen this is more of a a
commercial standpoint you're making
whether it's at the farmers market
making jelly or even producing apples to
sell to somebody and the other aspect of
inspection could be driven from private
sector uh that could even be something
related to um you know you as as a
consumer might drive a certain standard
that you'll be looking for in the food
that you would purchase for consumption
okay so moving on past the two subjects
here unless David has anything to chime
in
we'll move on to his notes Here in
background
thoughts okay David are you with
us I'm with you I had muted my button
sorry apologize all right the food
industry is more complicated than we may
realize the food laws in the United
States extend back to roughly 11 years
maybe even beyond that but over time as
issues have Arisen in our food industry
uh our laws have been expanded and I
think it's an accident but when you look
at the laws that we have for our food
industry I categorize them into five
sectors there's the laws that apply to
your input suppliers people that are
providing medic medicines for livestock
for example a second sector is the
agricultural producer the people with
the uh Orchard of trees the uh grain
Growers the livestock producers the
third sector would then be the food
processing where we take those EG
Commodities process them into food
products number four it becomes the
retail and the food service it's our
grocery stores as well as our
restaurants our cafeterias at our
institutions and then number five of
course is what we're all try striving to
serve and those are the consumers and
you look at the US laws and they really
do seem to fit into these five
categories again I don't think anybody
intended to be that way it just seems to
be the way it has evolved over the past
Century today we're going to primarily
focus on what are some of the rules for
those of us who are agricultural
producers for those of us who are food
processors for those of us who are
involved D in uh food retail sales and
many of the businesses in the food
industry fit into one of those
categories I'm a farmer so I'm in the
category of agricultural producer or I'm
a food manufacturer I'm a food processor
or I operate a grocery store uh I'm in
the retail sector but we also have
businesses and perhaps this is the type
of business that many of us are thinking
about this afternoon and that's a a
business that fits into several of these
sectors I might be raising the fruit on
my track of land I process that fruit
into a well keep it simple into a jam
and then I sell that jam or that jelly
at the retail sector so I find myself
with my simple business in all three of
these key sectors rather than just one
of these sectors So today we're going to
find ourselves trying to understand each
of these sectors at least a little bit
uh but I want you to have these three in
mind as we go forward
today we also have government
requirements whether it's federal
government requirements state government
requirements local government
requirements obviously government
requirements if we're subject to these
rules we must meet them we have no
choice there is also in the private
sector where businesses within the food
industry are documenting their
expectations they're formalizing their
expectations for the other food business
if I'm going to buy your food product
and use it in my food business and
whatever it is that I'm manufacturing
for the
consumer I expect you to meet certain
standards and to have some uniformity
among these standards try to make it a
little simpler for the industry the
industry is developing collaboratively
developing standards that we're going to
refer to today as private sector
standards or perhaps as food industry
standards so as a operator of even a
small firm I may find myself thinking
about the several different sectors of
the food industry in which I'm operating
I may find myself having to think about
the government regulations as well as
the private sector standards as we look
at those in this hour we're going to
find that there's some similarities
among the government
regulations and the industry standards
we're also going to see that there's
some
differences just a little graph then
that I use to try to organize my own
thinking we have the three sectors we
have the different uh levels of
expectations the the federal government
for example USDA and the FDA are the two
a are two of the agencies that uh have
lead responsibility for the food
industry what does the federal
government expect of our agricultural
producers it's often referred to as good
agricultural practices or Gap and here
we're going to see that in the past
several years it's especially in the
most recent year there are regulations
now that the
FDA needs to enforce for those Farm
operations that are producing fruits and
vegetables for example for The Fresh
Market what are those good agricultural
practices that I have to use in my
farming operation likewise the USDA and
FDA have regulations for the food
processors often those are referred to
as good Manufacturing practices or
sometimes they're referred to as
ssops standard sanitary operating
practices or procedures and then of
course there's the one that many of us
have heard about the hup the hazard
analysis and the preventive controls the
really isn't that much Federal
Regulation of retail and Food Service
we're going to find instead that the
retail and food service is primarily at
the state level so we move down one of
the roads in this graphic we for example
have the north Cota Department of Health
which has Authority and responsibility
for food processing within the state so
this is in collaboration with the
federal agencies but it also has then
the responsibility for the retail and
Food Service sectors the municipalities
the counties likewise have
responsibilities and they are combined
in with what I call the state and local
uh government regulations then we get
again to that private sector where the
Private Industry is setting forth
standards and we want to make sure that
those standards are being met those
private standards are being met with an
audit and certification process so just
a graphic to try to illustrate the
variety of topics that we're going to be
touching on this
afternoon yes and um just to add to it
saying we are going to elaborate a
little bit on the private sector and
what that means to you um but without
getting too overwhelmed on whoa what is
all this and what do I need to follow
we're gonna we're going to lay it out
for you so if you think about right now
in your mind what type of product you
produce we will get to it so in this
case let's say that you produce uh
apples for a farmers's market you're
likely going to fall under the Gap
agricultural producers sector and and if
you are processing anything we like to
use that example of maybe jelly or I I
saw canned goods last year you're under
the food processing sector couple of
examples okay we'll skip to the next
slide okay and
so again we're going to elaborate a
little bit about the private sector and
I'm G to I'm going to read the quote
here that we have the private sector
standards often take the form of
contracts and basically what these
contracts are saying is I'm not going to
purchase your product unless you can
document that your product is safe and
meets specific standards and sometimes
these buyers I'm thinking of a couple
examples Sam's Club Costco they have
different standards than uh maybe
Walmart might but every nearly every uh
retailer has some type of standard and
that's what we mean by private sector
standards that they require before
they're going to buy your product before
you as a consumer can even buy um so
we're we're saying to ourselves well
whose standards do we need to follow is
it the government is it private sector
well let's see here let's let's get into
it so we have a couple
enforcers we're going to break it down
between and really our answer to that
question that I left you rhetorically
here just a second ago was you may want
to consider both standards and sometimes
you have to what we have to follow is
the government and of course the
government enforces its regulations
we're going to give you a few examples
later on uh they do this through
inspection and so I have a couple
Graphics up here USDA uh and I heard
this quote from the grocery
manufacturers Association about five
years ago the GMA indicates that about
85% of what you are consuming is SDA
inspected from a federal standpoint now
and about 15% might be USDA okay so USDA
inspect anything
organic most all meat products that are
sold across the state border uh there's
a couple Exceptions there and uh eggs
within the shell you'll see that there's
an example of a mark of inspection here
that the USDA inspector that you can see
the plant number 38 they leave their
mark behind and you know that inspectors
were there the entire time that they
were
producing uh so the government is one
enforcer and the the other enforcer is
above and beyond the government and
these are the companies that say hey we
have a certain set of standards that
we're going to require sometimes above
and beyond federal or state or even your
Farmers Market inspections and that
leader is gfsi Global food safety
initiative and these are leaders across
industry and
Academia government organizations they
get together and they make sure that
there's a benchmark meaning that they're
kind of harmonizing an approach to
managing food safety across the industry
okay so we really have both standards
here and we're going to break down the
differences in a little
bit okay so David government
inspections okay so I'll take this here
in the beginning but we have meat and
poultry processing which is and I
mentioned it earlier we saw an example
of the mark of
inspection when when you're producing
meat and some of you might be on the
call that you know you you bring uh
grassfed beef or something too I know
here in bismar we have a great producer
brings grass-fed beef and many other
different types of red meat to our local
farmers market and they're very popular
um well they are typically locally
inspected but if they were to transport
across state lines they may need to be
USDA inspected and they actually might
be I I shouldn't quote exactly USDA is a
continuous inspection so if you're if
you're creating cuts of meat or
slaughtering from the hours of 7: am to
700 PM you're going to have an inspector
there the entire time so they can mark
that
inspection um we also have food
processing which is again regular
inspections by FDA and state this could
also be locally through your county
depending on what your setup is and this
actually is the majority and FDA doesn't
necessarily have a set particular time
they're not here 247 like USDA would be
in your facility I should say um they
are
really typically an annual basis okay
but you never know when they're going to
come so you always have to be operating
up to
standard and then you have your retail
and Food Services sectors where there
are regular inspections by state and
local and typically here's the neat
thing the results are usually posted
online and so when I go into uh sixth
grade sax classes or even ninth grade
High School uh I I pop these so that
they can see what's going on and they
feel kind of
empowered okay skipping on here David
are you
back well I tell you what I'm I I'll
take this and continue ongoing um so the
the examples that we're we're just
giving you a highlight here in this
slide this is kind of a boring slide but
honestly if we're going to tell you that
we have some examples of government
regulations and then what we're going to
do is we're going to pair up the
government regulations to the
differences in private sector why are we
giving you these examples we want you to
be empowered through your small business
and we're really targeting here anybody
that's producing especially for your
local markets your farmers markets to
come up with a food safety plan because
at some point this is going to apply to
you whether your Market has local
inspectors now or not they likely will
in the future we we want you to
maintain uh a certain level of safety
there we're going to discuss the
similarities and differences as we get
on uh to the next few slides
here okay so David here has a
slide okay so David is just commenting
in the bottom that we cannnot I I don't
don't believe that we can hear him so
I'm going to take the the hup uh food
processing regulation here that he's got
now whenever you see a
regulation uh from a federal standpoint
you're going to see typically it's title
21 now this is 21 which usually relates
to
FDA and then you have the Cod of reg
regulation so it's kind of like a
chapter 117 David was telling me earlier
that this 117 is new within a year
relative to the food safety
modernization act
feasa and so we have a written risk
control plan this is a food safety plan
with many different elements and you
know hup is actually now required across
all federal plants it it wasn't for a
very long time but what has the beauty
of hup even though it seems somewhat
mundane okay we've got to do all this
paperwor we have to make sure make sure
that we're demonstrating that we're
producing
safely you not only need to produce
safely but you have to demonstrate it on
paper well this is
preventing the onset of foodborn illness
that's the big thing here um it's and
this is especially important when you're
producing for consumers not just
somebody at home at your own dinner
table so we have you have you're
required to enhance it uh identify the
risks it could be
that you use a um let's say you're
making ground beef or um let's say that
you you you know there's a lot of metal
and one of your conveyor belts as you
wash your fresh produce from your
Farmers Market there might be a risk of
metal within your product so you are at
a point in which you you have to make
sure that you're mitigating that risk
that would be an example so there's a
few different types of risks we we have
physical we have chemical and then we
have biological which would be your
microorganisms again the the gist that
you need to know is that hup is required
by the government and if you don't have
a requirement now and you're producing
food to sell you may very well soon have
this requirement and it looks like David
might be back up and running here
soon we have hey wonderful to have you
we just get looked at slide number 17
David welcome back can you hear me this
time yeah we sure can thank you I'm
embarrassed that uh it didn't work out I
apologize and thank you for continuing
with the
comments
uh we just briefed over a little bit
about hup and and the necessity and
we're back on this slide okay number 16
or number 17 17 17 so do we need to go
forward
one more okay I think we explain cup
unless you need to
collaborate no I don't think I need to
uh expand on your discussion of hup we
can go on to the next
slide as we indicated we have the
processing
sector that is subject to hup the
federal government is primarily
responsible for the food processing
sector when it comes to the
retail and the food service sector most
of the regulatory responsibility lies
with our state and local
governments the task of developing
detailed regulations for each of the 50
states that becomes quite a challenge
you think about Minnesota having to
develop such a set of Standards Montana
having to develop such a set of
Standards North Dakota having developed
such a set of Standards so instead over
the past several decades the states
working with the Food and Drug
Administration have come up with
standards that are suggested that are
recommended to all of the state and
local governments so that way if the
state and local government wants to
adopt these detailed regulations so they
oversee the retail and Food Service
sectors of the industry they don't need
need they as the local governments they
as the state governments don't need to
start from Ground Zero they have a food
code to consider so the FDA working with
others has a food code that is suggested
to the state and local governments and
what do we have on this very busy slide
is simply some of the topics that are
included in the food code but it shows
the range of issues that we're always
thinking about in the food industry the
food retail the Food Service uh sectors
the management the Personnel are the
managers of the companies buying into
these responsibilities and making sure
that the firm is meeting these
expectations are the people who are
working in this firm even if it's only a
couple of individuals do they understand
the standards that they must function by
do they understand the practices that
they might must use for themselves
chapter three then is the food how do we
handle the food how do we make sure that
this food is being stored and handled
safely uh how do we make sure that the
food is being separated from or kept
separate from non-food products uh
number five the equipment or excuse me
chapter four the equipment the utensils
the Linens that we might use at our food
service uh
restaurant details
reminders as to what we need to do
within our business to have the safe
food product water plumbing and waste
disposal the physical facilities the
building itself is it clean is it is it
easy to be kept clean do we have the
proper lights do we have the proper
ventilation are we keeping the rodents
and others um undesirables outside of
the facilities these details are
addressed in the food code again the
food code developed by the FDA in
collaboration with others offered to the
state and local governments so that the
the state and local governments have a
solid foundation on which to develop or
in which to adopt regulations without
having to begin with a clean slate
instead they have solid suggestion
chapter number seven the poisonous and
toxic materials need to keep that
separate from the food want to keep that
separate from the food and then chapter
eight in the food code talks about the
compliance and the enforcement the
inspections and uh what is expected of
the firms so just a quick introduction
to the food code uh the topics at the
range of topics that are addressed in
the food code and that these are
suggestions for the state and local
governments to consider right and David
if I could give an example on that last
slide
now when you're talking about the food
code here's an example of when I've
encountered it from an audit standpoint
and Scott mentioned when I was first
introduced I was the food safety and
Technical Services director at
Cloverdale foods which is housed in
Mandan North Dakota over here near
bismar and we had an inspector that came
in at least once a year what sometimes
twice a year and they would audit us to
this food code at our retail store which
which is called The Country Store they
originally came up with this idea well
hey we have some Oddball packages of hot
dogs that we produced or maybe a hammer
two and we don't have enough at the end
of the run to put it in an entire box
but we want to make a couple bucks on
this perfectly good product well they
came up with this retail point so if we
were to Define retail and food service
for those of you who don't know exactly
what we're talking about that grocery
store that Country Store turned into a
retail point in addition to that they
said hey let's make some good sentes so
that because they're pretty far west of
town and there's not a lot of restaurant
options and they wanted people to get
back to their shift on time they came up
with a food service Point as well in
other words they were the last step
before consumers eat the product think
Deli now they they started making ham
sandwiches and things of this nature and
then they were turned they turned around
and became as well a food Serv service
venue so this food code is what they
were audited for so when we're going
through these standards think about how
it applies to your
business just a brief example a little
more detail on the Food Code we just
chose the inspection and the uh
correction of violations if there are
any just chose that as a topic to expand
on again the food code talks about the
frequency of the inspections this is
going to vary from state to state even
though uh the food code is suggested for
the entire nation uh annually and maybe
at least once every two years depends on
how the uh State or the local government
feels they are capable of conducting
these inspections uh the access to the
facility that certainly is expected that
one would be
uh uh one would be available for the
inspector
to look at your business to be able to
make sure that you are in compliance as
the inspection is completed the
inspector provides a report to the uh
firm as well as we've already been
indicated and report to the public as to
what was found if there were any
violations and
uh sometimes those even show up in the
newspaper if there's an imminent health
hazard something that catches the
inspector's atten that is very serious
uh there's authority to begin shutting
down the business until that type of a
serious health hazard is corrected uh so
these are just some of the type of
topics that are included in the food
code that a person would want to have
some
familiarity uh it you're not going to
study these documents necessarily in
extensive detail uh because they are uh
considerable amount of information in
them but you certainly want to have
yourself familiar with them and as you
identify the portions of these
regulations these government standards
that apply to your business yes you will
need to study those in
detail okay
right that's exactly right so now we've
we've elaborated a little bit on the
government requirements we talked about
hup earlier um we we kind of breezed
over a little bit about uh FD a as well
as USDA that has the hup inspections we
talked about the food code which
primarily relates to retail and food
service now we talked a little bit
earlier about the private sector we're
going to elaborate here a little bit uh
consumer and industry-driven
auditing again is above and beyond the
governmental inspections and you might
ask yourself whoa this is getting why
how does this apply to me this is
getting a little uh you know
globally here now this is above my level
but we want you to be aware of it
because the important thing here is that
consumers have a a very influential
drive here in the food safety sector uh
in
Industry consumers want to know what's
in their food and that really does
translate to a small kitchen oriented
business as it pertains to the farmers
market we want you to be familiar with
with uh gfsi and they're recognized
they're called schemes okay so
there's these are the various different
schemes and what we mean by that is uh
that let me just Define gfsi let me take
a step back I I kind of introduced it
earlier but gfsi is industry driven and
it provides guidance on Food Safety
Management Systems along the entire
supply chain so thank seed you know Farm
to tables okay and then and on our next
slide here we'll elaborate a little bit
about the different sectors of the
schemes um but really what this gfsi
represents it's an organization it
represents the leading food safety
experts whether they work in the retail
area manufacturing food service
companies this also includes government
as well as Academia NDSU extension as an
example uh so many different
organizations they meet across the globe
and they promote a benchmark standard so
that anybody that is sqf recognized or
fssc22000 or there's a brrc global
standard picture there in front of you
anybody that has one of these
certifications is above and beyond their
peers and you know that if I'm producing
a hot dog in India with sqf
certification it's going to be to the
highest food safety standard that it
would be here in the United States um
this especially applies Global Gap
specializes specifically in the
agricultural side of things so the
growing side of things so if you find a
producer of wheat or um you know tail or
you know think where we get during you
know up here in North Dakota it's cold
and we can't get fresh produce year
round well this if you you know as a
consumer as well as somebody who might
have a small business this is something
that pertains to you I know that these
are the recognized standards and they're
as good as I can get here in the United
States if they apply to the the same
certification so that's an introduction
to the various different types of
schemes and they're across a few
different let's skip to the next slide
now across a few different sectors so
the bubbles in blue there on the right
hand side of the of the screen it breaks
it down into the different types of
businesses that might apply to these
standards we have the agricultural
production okay David what's an example
of a product there do you think that
would apply to our Farmers Market
certainly would look at our fresh fresh
fruits and
vegetables uh that those are being
produced and then made available
directly to the
consumers yes absolutely and then also I
know once in a while we'll get those
beef fed or those grass-fed beef uh
producers or your pork producers that
could also be food processing now when
we talk processing that's anything that
alters it from its original state that
could be smoking of meat uh mixing
salting uh chopping grinding you know
the government does Define processing uh
but this could be that you folks who are
making we have a wonderful producer of
sourdough bread here at our Farmers
Market bismar that SAR bread I mean I
try to stock up during the summer so
that would be a processing example uh we
also have the the standard applies of
retail and food service and there's also
a sector in there for under retail and
food service for if you're just housing
product there is a standard to make sure
that you're doing it right you're
keeping it temperature controlled if it
applies and all kinds of things so these
are the different standards and these
are broken into the categories farming
of animals of fish of plants grains and
pulses is a separate
one uh all kinds of things all the way
down to uh production of seed that's
very
important production of food packaging
so the people who are making the
Plastics make sure that the polymers
don't leak into our food these are some
examples okay how are these Audits and
certifications handled um if if I want
to be certified uh do I need to apply to
one of these schemes and then if I am
part of one of these schemes how do the
people who operate the schemes monitor
my actual
activities do you want to answer that
one well that's a great
question yeah that's a great question
and really what they do is you have at
least an annual audit and what they do
is they typically can go through and
we'll talk about this later your record
your paperwork from the entire last year
that they were there typically they'll
go through the last 90 days of
documentation so an example would be we
talked a little bit earlier about uh
laundering and Pest Control uh they
would look at the last 90 days of
Records to make sure that any of the
smoks or lab coats that we used were
washed in a with a chemical that
would verify that no microorganisms were
able to live whether it was a high
enough temperature or a chemical that
killed it so when you're producing jelly
in your kitchen you want to make sure
and have clean overgarments or
protective gear when when you're doing
your processing you know so that is it's
by way of audits I hope answer the
question does anyone have any questions
right there is honey considered
processed I see we have a
question that's a good question I I'm
going to start out with the answer and
David could probably uh continue it
depends is the answer and I will say
that some honey you can you hear of the
term raw honey okay
is uh typically filtered and that would
not be considered a process because it
would still be at same state um honey in
the past and I don't have the numbers in
front of me and I don't want to scare
anybody but has been associated with one
particular microbe that lives in an an
anerobic environments so no air there um
and so usually when you get honey
especially from the store there has been
through the hasset plan that we
mentioned earlier a critical step to
make sure that that bug has been
eradicated and usually that's a heated
step so it it Heats it now some people
believe that it gets rid of some of the
natural entities that are within the
honey when it's uh heated heating is a
process so the majority of what you get
at your retail point is heated people
come to a farmers's market sometimes to
get the raw honey but then you need to
know the risk there that you know there
there is a slight very slight
possibility you would have a microbe
there oh I have not David I don't know
if you want to elaborate other questions
please yeah please be sure to send them
out what we want to do now for the next
few moments is just to make a comparison
between the FDA regulations and some of
the private sector standards and we've
just chosen uh for the purpose of our
discussion this afternoon some good
agricultural practices and remember good
agricultural practices means that we're
talking about what's going on on the
farm or what's going on in the vineyard
or the Orchard and you look at the FDA
regulations as was introduced earlier
this afternoon when you see part 112
that particular regulation is less than
a year old but here are some of the
topics that the FDA Reg Ates uh in terms
of what's going on on our farm operation
the qualification of the Personnel the
training of the Personnel their hygiene
practices the health of the Personnel we
don't want an ill individual handling
our food while it's being processed
agricultural water is the water uh such
that it's not going to add contaminants
to our uh agricultural commodity or to
our food what type of biological
uh items are we are we adding to our
soils are we properly composting the
waste materials that we might be wanting
to use in our soils how about the
presence of animals and so forth so we
see a list of topics that these are some
of the uh details that the FDA addresses
with good agricultural practices now
let's look at the private sector we
chose sqf just as an example and sqf
they address what are the requirements
for the site where we are handling this
fresh fruit fruits and vegetables on the
farm how are we handling the product
how's it being stored again the personal
hygiene and Welfare what are the
practices of packaging the Water
Management the soil management the
harvesting practices by go we begin to
recognize the government regulations and
the private sector standards they are
addressing many of the same concerns
they're not identical but there certain
certainly are commonalities so we going
to go into a little more detail and
again we've just Chosen One FDA
regulation to illustrate here are some
of the expectations that the federal
government has in the United States if
you're dealing with products that are
being produced on the farm being handled
and prepared so that they can go
directly to The Fresh Market uh this is
what we need to be thinking about we
need to be thinking about the equipment
the knives the implements the mechanical
Harvesters the cooling equipment the
belts the conveyors on which the food is
passing as we are handling it and
getting it ready so here are just some
of the details in this type of a
regulation are these items up to
standards in terms of making sure we
minimize the risk of contaminating the
food looking a little further into that
FDA regulation are you using equipment
and tools that are of design and built
in a way that they're easily clean
because we certainly don't want to have
an item that we can't get clean and
therefore we risk contamination as we
continue to use it are is the facility
clean is it easy to clean the facility
is the product being stored and
maintained in a way that uh again
minimizes the risk we continue one step
further and we look at this regulation
in a little more detail and this is just
one of multiple regulations but here
again uh how is the equipment built is
it built in such a way that the the
scenes where the pieces of metal come
together uh are easy to clean and we're
we're hopefully uh able to keep the uh
equipment free of contaminants are we
inspecting this equipment to make sure
that it's clean are we maintaining the
equipment so that it doesn't get damaged
and therefore become a a point of risk
in our business are we uh using it in
the proper way are we sanitizing it
properly uh the equipment the tractors
the forklifts the other vehicles the
containers in which the foods are being
set are these being used in such a way
that we are reasonably reducing the risk
uh that are foreseeable within our
business operation so here is a very
quick and dirty example of a Federal
Regulation and now let's take a look at
what are some of those fundamental
requirements from the private
sector okay right and so then we move
into we're still using our example of
sqf and uh we you know I'm going to
start pointing out the similarities now
sqf breaks it into modules okay and it
doesn't matter what type of business
what type of product you're producing
everybody in sqf has to follow module
two so you know that if whether it's uh
canned good or if it's h
shrimp the premises the building and all
the equipment just like the FDA
regulation indicated needs to be done uh
you know basically handled in a safe
manner in order to produce the delivery
of safe food so um next in in the code
we have the supplier then needs to
follow whatever module is relative
whether it's module 3 to 15 relative to
the type of food product they're
producing so for those of you on the
next slide now in module 7 who are
producing the fresh fruits and
vegetables which is the majority of our
Market farmers markets uh you want to
make sure that you're following these
things okay so your Machinery especially
your conveyors uh your harvesting and
processing rigs are of sound
construction then they'll break it down
a little bit further the contact
surfaces of the conveyors which is why I
said especially uh harvesting and
processing rigs shall be designed and
constructed and and you can read here an
an efficient way of handling the product
so that any surfaces that directly and
this goes across the board any surfaces
that directly hit the consumable portion
of the food contact or food surfaces so
we call it direct contact is is cleaned
and handled in a way that will mitigate
food faes
risk so you know the example I can give
here when when I think of knives totes
um trays I appreciate that they're
actually giving some examples the FDA
example gave a couple of the same
examples so really this is this is
benchmarking the standard and you might
say well why the
similarities okay well it looks like
you're not really going above and beyond
with sqf beyond what the regulation
requires because remember this is
industry driven well the the novelty
here with the private sector AIT is that
you're benchmarked across the globe okay
so you're able to export and import and
all of a sudden you have more
opportunity to make more money okay the
bigger your Market is so again that's
why we're here there are some
similarities the novelty in our country
is that our government requires things
to be very similar so you don't have to
come up with two sets of Standards so
for the most part our message is as
you're creating standards for your
farmers market and producing safe
product this is a start looking at these
examples that we've given you here the
knives um the containers that you're
using so uh let me skip to the next
slide and continue this is the last
slide of examples here the water tanks
are sufficient um clean at the right
frequency so maybe it's a monthly maybe
you can demonstrate that they're not
dirty within the month so a month is
long enough and you can do that by you
know plating the microorganisms whatever
your um you know setup is you can you
can show in your kitchen that there just
isn't any obvious signs of grime until
you know you know for two weeks and then
that's what your cleanliness frequency
is you get to set that up uh one more
example here I am typically the one who
goes out to our 4 camp in Washburn to
set up our kitchen last year was a huge
year for us as a lot of you might know
with the grant uh at the new building we
also and I I credit the director Brad
for ensuring and sticking to his guns on
making sure that the knives and the
totes and all the different plates that
are used out there are commercially
certified I'm bringing this example up
because it pertains to well you're
thinking about starting a business where
you make jelly for the farmers market
and jam and preserves well what kind of
equipment should you buy the auditor his
name is Anton here in Burley County and
the City of bismar he's with the
Environmental Health Department they're
located at the Public Health Building he
is the one who and his team and he
typically goes around and Audits and the
first thing that he'll look for is
certified commercially
represented forks and knives and and you
know metal mixing bowls he knows that if
he sees these commercially stamped uh
knives and forks and Cutlery that he
knows you know what you're doing and I'm
not endorsing any one particular product
brand but NSF is an example of one of
those commercially uh recognized and
certified um cutlery uh manufacturers is
what I'm trying to say and so if you see
NSF on your forks when you're out at the
I just ate at a steakhouse here on
Sunday and I saw that NSF was stamped in
their Forks so you can start looking for
that I would spend a little extra money
on the commercially commercial kitchen
recognized equipment if if you're
starting from scratch okay uh so this is
an example of uh you know how you you
have to have a way to clean it but you
can start out with the right stuff okay
so moving on here David I'll pass it you
to interiew our discussion this
afternoon has been talking about what's
going on on the farm what's going on in
the processing facility what occurs in
the retail the previous example the
several slides were in uh detailed
example of what goes on in the farm the
next several slides and we'll go through
these quickly because of the interest of
time but now we're going to be looking
at a quick comparison between government
regulations and private sector standards
when it comes to that food processing
facility those good manufacturing
practices the gmps here we look at again
the broad topics that the FDA addresses
in its regulations the plant is the
facility the building itself the
sanitation practices that we're using in
the operation the again the equipment
the utensils that are being used during
the manufacturing process what is the
actual manufacturing process and how are
we controlling the process to minimiz
the risk how's the food being uh
warehouse and stored uh what do we do if
there are some uh problems now we look
at the private sector what does a
private sector uh concern itself with
and those standards again I would
suggest they begin to look this similar
what are the requirements for the site
and are these is the site being approved
according to these private sector
standards the construction and the
control of handling the product storing
the product the Personnel hygiene and
their welfare the Personnel processing
practices the importance of training the
Personnel the water the ice the air that
comes in contact with the food while the
food is being processed the storage
Transportation separating the function
of where we're cleaning the raw
materials from where we're packaging the
final materials let's not have those
occurring in the same space so that we
minimize the risk of
cross-contamination waste disposal and
then how are you maintaining the
exterior of your facility so we look at
the government regulations we look at
the private sector standards and again
we see similarities just some very brief
examples uh the sanitary operations
these are details of what the FDA
requires when it comes to processing the
food how do we assure that we have a
sanitary operation the general
maintenance of the building are the
substances being clean and sanitized
where are we store ing the toxic
materials uh what's necessary for actual
testing of the product to make sure that
our product is safe continuing with this
example the control of the pests that we
know that the rodents the insects and so
forth are not uh gaining access to the
food why it's being processed the food
contact surfaces are sanitized and that
they're meeting the sanitation standards
while the food is being processed in
whatever the manufacturing practices
that we're using in our business and con
then the sanitation of even nonf food
contact Services surfaces we want to
make sure that we are not contaminating
the product so after we look at the
Federal Regulations very quickly now
let's take a quick look at the uh
private sector standards are they
similar or are there some
differences right and the answer to that
really is they're very similar in in um
the US here and so what they do here
with the sqs standard is they get a
little bit more particular and they
start naming like in the 11 to
12.2 you'll see benches tables conveyors
mixers mincers they they actually
include a few examples for you which
helps when you're creating your plan um
but the the big message here is that
they are pressing how often how often
you're or really not how often it's that
you need to clean the equipment that
you're producing what I'm trying to say
is that it's still your business you get
to decide how you're doing it so like I
said how often you get to decide but the
thing is is that you've got to stick to
it because this is what you have to do
okay so you you get a little leway there
we're saying well um you as you go
through the me methods of cleaning and
handling food processing equipment you
need to consider what is to be cleaned
how it's to be cleaned when it's to be
cleaned they're not telling you exactly
the details of how it needs to be in
your business because you might have
extenuating circumstances but this is
what needs to be done okay very very
similar to regulation and again this is
for anything being processed in this
example okay um one example I can give
you is in the 13.6 detergents and
sanitizers well they're saying you've
got to use some type of detergent
remember gets rid of the oilbased food
food uh bofilm so any food products that
are on there but the sanitizer is what's
going to kill the microorganisms the
detergent doesn't necessarily eradicate
the the microorganisms and so if you're
thinking about your own food processing
bench in your kitchen when you're
producing maybe your souro bread or
something um are you using a sanitizer
and a detergent and and and really it
should go s detergent rinse sanitizer
and don't rinse and an example that I
can give you you know as you can see
here the module nor did the regulation
say you've got to be using bleach or
you've got to be using quinary and
pneumonia or ammonia it won't say what
you have to do exactly how you have to
do it but it'll say you've got to be
clean an example of a sanitizer that you
can mix up and you should do it fresh
each time you're going to use it is a
gallon of Bach to a table I'm sorry a
gallon of water that's important other
way around a gallon of water to a
tablespoon of bleach and that's
considered a food contact surface safe
parts per million for a sanitizer it
will kill the bugs you don't have to
rinse it off okay so let's uh let's go
just a couple more slides here we're
right on time hopefully we get a couple
we often have heard farmers in the past
20 years say I spend more time at my
desk than I do on my tractor or working
with my livestock that might be true for
our small food firms as well we're going
to feel like there's a point that I'm
spending more time at the uh computer
than I'm doing uh that I'm spending in
the orchard or that I'm spending with
the product but it is so important as
already been described this afternoon we
need to document how this business is
being operated but also as stated
earlier this afternoon before we even
start the operation we need a document
in which we describe how we intend to
operate the business we need that plan
as to how we're going to operate to
minimize these risks then we need to
keep records uh as the business is
actually being conducted this is how we
harvested this is how we handled the
food so that we minimize the risk this
is how we processed it this is how we
kept it warm to the necessary
temperatures or this how we kept it cool
to the required uh temperature again so
we end up having the documents as to our
planning and then the documents as to
how we keep records this is important
and hopefully we've emphasize this
throughout the afternoon that the
government inspectors are going to be
looking for these records as well as
looking at your facilities the private
sector Auditors are going to be looking
for these records as well as taking a
look at these at your facilities and I
would add if you end up ever end up with
that ill consumer hopefully you never do
but if you end up with that ill consumer
and that consumer gets a lawyer and
comes to you and says your product was
unsafe that lawyer is going to be
looking at your documents as well and
you're going to want to have those
documents in place for the inspector
documents in place for the Auditors
you're going to want to have those in
documents in place to prove to the
lawyers prove to the court that you uh
handled the food safety and you were not
the cause of this person's
illness that's right I we can't
elaborate enough on this slide to keep
your records and you might say well what
kind of Records do I need I mean go back
up and look at the different examples
that we gave you and you can start
establishing little programs little
prerequisite programs we call them you
know pest control program you might Set
uh traps or even have fly bait traps and
you check them once a month that would
be a record that you would keep you may
keep that you started your production at
88 a.m. and you sanitized all of the Sur
food contact surfaces with uh your 200
parts per million bleach solution I gave
you that would be an example of a record
you would start so we can't we can't
stress the last slide this afternoon
then is to say okay does my firm need to
comply with all of these standards and
the answer
some of our small firms no you don't but
on the other hand the consumers are
beginning to expect the food industry to
meet these standards even if you are not
legally required by regulation to meet
all these standards at this time I would
suggest if you look to the Future begin
to uh take the time become familiar with
these standards begin to adopt these
standards in your practice in your
business because at some point they will
be upon all of
us that's exactly right um you know
anybody who is producing food for other
people especially for profit at some
point you are going to have some type of
audit or requirements uh from a food
safety inspection standard that that
you'll have to undergo your business
so maybe not every one of these
regulations applies but but the the
standards are there that you should us
up we can uh stay online for another
minute or two to see if there are any
questions I don't see any questions at
this point uh thank you was great to be
part of this two-person team and to have
the opportunity to be part of this
program any
questions thank you everybody okay thank
you everyone
look